vous avoir des hébergements beaucoup
plus authentique dont vous pouvez
voyager avec tout ce type cloud approche
et l'entretien va durer ainsi pendant
une heure thomas va leur proposer six
hôtels dix activités et à force il finit
par cerner les attentes de sa cliente
alors il va dénicher une visite
inattendue qui correspond à la
personnalité d'aurore
cela par exemple dans ce cas là c'est
qui travaillait pour les effets spéciaux
nude qui a pris sa retraite et qui a
causé un musée des beatles le premier
musée plus prisés des beatles aux
aurores et conquise alors elle se lâche
pour ce voyage de noces elle réserve dix
jours à hawaii pour elle et son futur
mari cela comprend un aller retour
depuis paris ainsi que des vols internes
des nuits d'hôtel dans des suites sur
deux îles différentes la location d'une
voiture et même un survol de l'île en
hélicoptère ou encore une excursion en
catamaran
résultat plus de 8000 euros pour ce
voyage sur mesure
c'est maintenant ou jamais
dans ce genre d' agences avoir un
conseiller spécialisé passé une heure
avec lui dans des locaux chic tout cela
a un coût élevé alors comment est il
possible de casser les prix sur des
séjours personnalisé et en attend
vraiment pour son argent
révélations sur les coulisses de ses
voyages individualisé qui nous séduisent
de plus en plus
a priori quand on organise un voyage sur
mesure il faut s'attendre à casser sa
tirelire car dans ce domaine les
dépenses peuvent vite atteindre des
sommes astronomiques
et pour s'en rendre compte il suffit
d'aller chez le leader du secteur
voyageurs du monde
à l'intérieur sur trois étages c'est en
un vaste espace équivalent à 30 agences
de voyages un décor tendance tout chaque
continent à son espace conseil
ici par exemple c'est le coin asie
et tous les clients sont choyés thé et
café à volonté
et pour les conseillers des dizaines de
chargés de clientèle ultra qualifiés
tous spécialistes d'un pays du monde
mais depuis peu face à voyageurs du
monde de nouveaux concurrents sont
apparus des entrepreneurs audacieux qui
ont décidé de rendre accessible à tous
ces voyages sur mesure en cassant les
prix
aujourd'hui ils sont une dizaine en
france
et parmi eux il y en a un qui domine ce
nouveau marché le pionnier du secteur
evaneos
il propose jusqu'à 20% de réduction par
rapport à des agences traditionnelles
avec parfois des tarifs à peine croyable
chez lui un séjour à hawaï comparable à
la lune de miel de rohr revient à moins
de 3000 euros et même en rajoute en 2000
euros de billets d'avion cela reste 30 %
moins cher que chez une agence
traditionnelle
[Musique]